enterprises episodio è più bello
oddio zaza uguale non sei scappare la
stessa cosa che riuscito a fare zaza i
mondiali
[Applauso]
molto meglio e ho mica un'ora come tutti
i video della domenica ormai è
consuetudine
ecco le cose fatte bene sembra giusto
per tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono fa vide ed oggi siamo tornati
su happy meals che è un gioco nuovo che
faccio oggi sul mio canale caffè click
mi to start va bene con che grafica me
lo sta dicendo questa scritta a ok e io
so fare bello storia difficile una prova
vuol dire atletica ma veramente ragazzi
ci sto impegnando sul serio wow
non mi ricordo tutti ma volta che ho
fatto un livello così difficile proprio
stata una sfida è messo a dura prova le
mie capacità di f
porca [ __ ]
dalla vita e giocasta roba c'è un almeno
fare i velivoli decenti minecraft sword
york il bello
bello perché ho perso sette secondi
eventi nella mia vita così senza un
motivo poco gianpi york sono figli non
ne faccio sì però dovete stare tutti i
cani io non ne faccio tipo mai mai mai
mai mai di fuoco jump non so perché ha
sì ecco perché adesso ho capito che mi
fa cagare tra l'altro è ce l'ha è moscio
questo coso emotion per chi mi avete
preso forse è una frase un po tu che
cazzo stai facendo zio
cos'è successo raga non ho capito
neanch'io prova bene albertino posso mai
farmi battere uno si chiama albertino no
grazie
no no albertino oggi non mi avrai mi
piace magari domani da uno che si chiama
bertino noi ragazzi mi rifiuto chiudo il
canale è uno che si chiama albertino mi
rifiuto albertino del cazzo ti prende a
schiaffi ma fammi capire o no ma allora
se i [ __ ]
ma perché lo dice a passare sto punto ma
il problema o amiche un'ora è facebook
shift ma è un ora che sto facendo così
non va lo stesso
sapete qual è il motivo del perché non
faccio mai poco jump è questo il cazzo
di motivo sono rotto le palle pirati mio
casco tore gam basta e albero abbattuto
albertino l'importante era quello alla
fine si mi vai bello 6 durato molto
perfetto si ok guido subito quindi devo
veramente adesso liuc è parato andare in
bici non ti serve seggio lo [ __ ] a
parte che non si usa così bravo figlio
porta a tuo padre è diventato il
contrario risolveva non ci voglio
credere
però il problema è che uk non è non
essendo allenato non sa fare neanche un
centimetro
questo potrebbe essere un problema
capitare
ok vai zio vai zio mezzi o porta a tuo
padre a spasso ti ho portato per 130
episodi portami tu adesso siccome questo
livello è molto carino no perché sono
messo pieno di ostacoli inutili
ecco ecco come vai da solo figlio il
suicidio finale merita tutto il video
ragazzo bello pollice in su mixed games
epic botta factor bowles
niente devo beccare cosa ne è del
perfetto l'ho centrato in pieno proprio
no no vado dove mi sono salvato no porca
eva lercio è un casino [ __ ]
riproviamo caneva ok no alla madonna che
palle
una persona inutile ma perché hai sempre
lite problemi che disturbi che hai o
sguardo troppo questo posso fare porca
eva perfetto questo anche non sapevo
fare se non fossi rincoglionito
no dai dall'inizio no rega ti prego
iddio mi chiama è difficile beccare
questo perché è nonno dietro lo pescare
quel giusto effetto non ci riescono john
quel problema perché non riesco perché
non riesco completino ammazzare la
famiglia dai dai dai dai dai dai
ammazzalo uno è poche però mica un ora
che gioco di merda ragazzi cambiamo
anche perché non mi sembra there is no
ma non c'è nessuna mappa thank you for
not playing questa è la porta quale pur
non vedo a quella è la porta perfetto
non cliccare verde ok io andiamo va bene
sei un prog ragazzi e ora immagino che
sia tutto fake giusto è tutto ok
come sei simpatico non faceva ridere
penso che sia divertente no come
l'unicità fa veramente pena un po con la
mia clic su start the ok va bene sempre
meglio del livello di primis challenge
non challenge challenge che un parente
dei cullen ma devo prendere la ok che
figo bravo gli who complimenti io non
devo fare così giusto quindi facciamo di
nuovo sì ma quando a proseguirlo ok no
perché se ne era andato a caso benissimo
benissimo bravo io ho una roba decente
che fa ragazzi non ci posso credere la
prima volta che lui fa una roba decente
in 130 episodi la prima la prima ok
potreste anche vincere sai dovessero una
sorpresa incredibile per una volta nella
vita
[Musica]
e vabbè mica limbo perfetto grande gli
uguali uguali o vai you terzo ce l'ho
fatta perfetto
dai dai dai dai non ci voglio credere
che gioco del cazzo che sta diventando
questo che gioca nel caso oztorun easy
ma magari se easy un livello forse lo
finisco forse no credo di no al piano
barrio barrio barrio perfetto avete mai
visto un finale più poetico di questo
[Musica]
dunk contest
ah ok altro che caso di palla è questa e
la palla vasche più brutta che abbia mai
visto
vabbè da regalo non va bene tu a cosa ti
era in quella palla da basket canestro
gli house ma veramente ma che bomba
[ __ ] vacca io al potere sucate melo è
tra l'altro in tutto questo il
televisore era rimasto intatto però non
sono riuscito a farlo vedere
ok in tutto questo comunque televisore è
rimasto intatto che è importante che
continua a guardare uomini e donne a
dare bari talebani beni è ok guadagnato
un mattone ok televisore andato giù il
tipo si sta magna l'ananas in questo
momento ma ti pare al momento giusto
spike sly a cipro stai calmo
devo andare ok che tu hai a volte
difficile
e vabbè mi chiamo segue un casino
ragazzino ha mai fatto livello del
genere aspettare un attimo è
interessante perché nuovo
tutto nel culo boxing di mustafa mica se
ti chiami mustafà zio non possono farlo
suo livello vedi come sono bravo mustafa
porca [ __ ] visto che bravo mustafa
perfetto no vabbè dai facciamo il giro
che palle che sono tutti wire hop singh
fanno tutti sta cosa che cerco su che
gira tutti uguali non so perché c'era
stato prima un cristiano che l'ha
inventato per primo nicchia grazie
mustafa di questo bel livello di questi
21 secondi e 73 decimi passati a vivere
bene olympic knife through porca eva
cazzo cielo quasi o per altro si è
impigliato sorry e stato lui non sono
boomerang e queste sono mannaie quindi è
stato lui non hanno fatto un cazzo per
beccare il centro cazzo che si propaga
ma perché si impigliano col manico a
questo semplice tab è però non è il
centro
porca eva difficilissimo
[Musica]
scusate non volevo cento
nice shock tra l'altro mi ha dato a
perché hanno non conta quanto quante
volte beck il centro ma quante volte
centri porsche bersagli ok non ci voglio
credere mai che culo
eva è lui hai tratto sarà stai zitto
sarà l'unico che ebbe che ho tra l'altro
tra tutti quanti invece no
madonna che mira di me ok va bene va
bene anche così gioco del cazzo vabbè
ragazzi concluso che questo episodio di
è più visto che ne abbiamo già viste
tante forse era meglio lasciar perdere
sei video è piaciuto consente lasciato
argomento è un mi piace anche i vari
social che come nei video trovate la
descrizione che si scateni ci rimettiamo
prossimo bene ragazzi